[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 20 janvier très heureux de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce journal emmanuel
macron réuni 200 patrons de grands
groupes français et mondiaux le
troisième sommet choose france se
déroule aujourd'hui au château de
versailles un objectif inciter à
investir en france nous serons sur place
dans un instant à maurepas il sera
candidat pour la deuxième fois aux
élections municipales ismail havane
membres de l'opposition de gauche mènera
la liste maurepas dynamique et solidaire
c'est dans la page dédiée enfin
d'édition et puis à guyancourt un
festival consacré au septième art la
semaine du cinéma étranger débute à
partir d'aujourd'hui au programme quatre
films et six courts métrages projetés un
événement préparé par les étudiants de
l'ue vs qu à suivre également tout à
l'heure ce qu'il faut retenir des
résultats sportifs du week-end mais
direction tout de suite le château de
versailles le président de la république
qui réunit des patrons français et
étrangers troisième édition du sommet
choose france nicolas d'ombrie bonsoir
vous êtes sur place pour la rédaction de
tv 78 environ 200 grands groupes sont
représentés au château de versailles
aujourd'hui effectivement grégory ça a
commencé avec le déjeuner avec les
membres du gouvernement et ces grands
patrons venus du monde entier
les membres du gouvernement ont ensuite
rencontré ses patrons objectif pour eux
vente et l'attractivité économique et
financière de la france des présents
aussi des parlementaires de la
république en marche des yvelines et
parlementaires députés et sénateurs et
notamment l'écouté marie le bec
parlementaire de la république en marge
des huiles beaucoup d'interrogations
bien sûr sur la réforme des retraites
sur comment est-ce que ça impacter notre
capacité à des formules puisque bien sûr
c'est ce que les investisseurs vont
regarder et en même temps le fait de
considérer que la politique que l'on
mène depuis deux ans et demi elle a
permis d'alléger un certain nombre de
contraintes tissement annoncé dans la
journée ericsson le groupe de
télécommunications suédois qui annonce
installé ouvrir son centre de recherche
et développement pour développer la 5g à
massy au pôle d'innovation de paris
saclay écoutez le pdg de cette
entreprise et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur federighi
tallevende est vantée par dont les
mérites de ce pôle d'innovation
si on le met là pour le moment c'est
parce que à côté de chez nous il ya le
paris saclay et là on y trouve à la fois
des compétences on étouffe des
industries et on peut construire un
écosystème qui va être favorable à notre
développement
on regarde beaucoup d'événements
sportifs comme étant un élément tangible
d'implémentation décade usage de la 5g
spécifiquement le vélodrome pas
forcément mais s'il ya une opportunité
pour le faire on le fera une véritable
opportunité pour ericsson de se trouver
là encore dans un écosystème académique
excellent et puis ce qui nous permettra
de porter la question de la 5g avec une
vision beaucoup plus nationale et
européenne
au total 8 milliards d'euros
d'investissements ont été annoncées
durant cette journée
merci nicolas d'andré qui est présent
château de versailles pour cette
troisième édition du sommet choose
france et en marge de cette actualité
45e jour de grève contre la réforme des
retraites plusieurs organisations
réunies en intersyndicale on
profitez-en pour ont profité de la venue
du chef de l'état pour une action une
centaine de personnes a participé à
cette mobilisation dans les rues de la
cité royale
un cortège réunissant cgt fo fsu et
solidaires qui a défilé de la gare des
chantiers jusqu'au château de versailles
au chapitre économie toujours cette
démarche pour le moins originale pour
trouver de nouveaux collaborateurs
candidats et recruteurs se rencontrent
et grâce aux arts martiaux c'est le
groupe thales implantée à elancourt qui
a proposé cette session particulière de
recrutement c'était en fin de semaine
dernière au palais des sports de la
ville le reportage de nicolas d'andry du
karaté du taekwondo du kendo à la place
de l'entretien d'embauché traditionnels
voilà la session de recrutement
organisée par thales une vingtaine de
candidats à participer à cet événement
innovant un premier contact établi avec
les recruteurs à travers une initiation
à ces disciplines
ça change énormément du recrutement
habituel en fait ça permet vraiment
d'être décontracté de voir une autre
vision en fait du recrutement classique
au début un peu stressé intimider
on communique facilement et on se met à
l'aise très vite candidats et recruteurs
se retrouvent au même niveau dans une
position d'apprentissage des arts
martiaux le moyen de déceler des
potentiels pour le site thalès
d'elancourt je pense que ma relation en
tant que manager avec mes collaborateurs
et la confiance que je leur donne et que
leur attribue je trouve qu'on retrouve
cette cette image là dans les arts
martiaux je trouve que déjà le
comportement la posture le dialogue qui
s'instaure la fuite et qui peut
s'installer entre nous rien par un petit
échange on décèle ça on essaie de cette
ouverture osé essayer je trouve que sa
place à transparaît tout de suite dans
les changes
j'ai déjà envie de retrouver des jeunes
filles avec qui je discutais là et voilà
d'en savoir plus sur elle respect
détermination agilité et écoute les
valeurs défendues par thales des
comportements essentiels dans la
pratique des arts martiaux l'attitude
corporelle il
les personnes qui vont y aller tout de
suite s'impliquer dans les démarches
c'est ce qui s'applique aux arts
martiaux peu s'impliquent s'appliquait
dans le monde professionnel
après l'initiation les candidats ont pu
échanger avec les recruteurs des
discussions autour des postes proposés
par le groupe industriel spécialisé dans
le secteur de la défense d'arts martiaux
il en était question ce week-end à abu
en cours la ville a posé samedi la
première pierre symbolique de deux
nouvelles salles dédiées à la pratique
au gymnase maurice baquet est les
travaux ont débuté lundi et devrait
durer un an un équipement de 800 m² avec
en plus des deux salles des vestiaires
et salles de rangement il profitera en
toi 600 adhérents 17 associations d'arts
martiaux et guyancourt toise les propos
sont recueillis par marylène yapi chez
nous cette salle est leur évidemment de
manière tout à fait prioritaire dédié
puisque jusque là ces clubs et
associations utilisé par exemple des
gymnases voilà et donc ça va avoir comme
effet domino forte important de pouvoir
ensuite faire bénéficier à d'autres
associations les créneaux de gymnase qui
vont ainsi être libéré
habituellement s'entraîne dans une salle
de boxe
et en fait on est plutôt à l'étroit là
ce qui va changer c'est que maintenant
ce sera vraiment une salle d'arts mars
où et quand on dit ça redémarre sur la
plupart du temps les soldats romains se
sont plutôt grand et l'avantagé qu'on
nous rase et aussi au niveau du tatami
parce qu'en fait à la salle de boxe de
guyancourt c'est pas un tatami et ce qui
se passe souvent c'est qu'il ya des
entorses il ya des gens qui sont mal aux
pieds elle reste avec nous les résultats
sportifs du week-end à suivre dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord une
parenthèse culturelle on reste à
guyancourt l'association culture sans
frontières propose une semaine du cinéma
étranger quatre films et six courts
métrages projetés à la maison martap
année aussi à la maison de quartier
joseph kosma pour en parler
deux invités clara ollier israël bashung
à sanaa bonsoir à vous deux pour ce que
vous êtes tous les deux étudiants en
master de projets culturels
internationaux donc ce projet on peut
lire il est tout à fait en lien avec vos
études
c'est ça exactement exactement en fait
le projet que nous réalisons à partir de
cette semaine se déroule dans le cas de
notre projet de collectif de fin
d'études
en somme nous avons dans notre classe
nous sommes 19 et il y a trois groupes
et chacun des groupes organisent un
projet le nôtre est en lien avec le
cinéma
un autre est en lien avec le paiera et
le dernier avec un musée à versailles et
vous faites au travers de cette
association culture seront frontières
qui existaient déjà et qui vous permet
d'organiser ce genre d'événement
exactement en fait l'association ses
parfums la société créée par des
étudiants du master il ya but ou trois
ans et chaque année les différentes
promos se passe le flambeau afin
d'organiser des événements dans la ville
de guyancourt et aux alentours
alors pourquoi pour cet événement pour
ce projet que vous menez vous avez
choisi de cibler le cinéma étranger
pourquoi ce choix le cinéma étranger
tout d'abord parce que c'est l'événement
s'organise en partenariat avec le fils
ep qui est un qui mène un partenariat
avec notre master depuis plusieurs
années maintenant
et cet événement est originellement un
organisées à paris et le fils elle nous
a tout simplement proposé de s'inspirer
de sept mois j'ai et bleu pouvoir le
transposer un nouveau public et une
nouvelle audience qui se trouvent encore
juste le fils est pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas et last le forum des
instituts étrangers comme un défaut le
forum des instituts culturels étrangers
à paris
alors le cinéma étranger on a compris
donc pour ce choix commence à se
préparer un tel événement comme en ont
choisi les films comment au programme
tout ça on avait le choix dans parmi une
liste de 50 films donc après on a on a
on a essayé de regarder les films voir
qu'est ce qui nous plaisait qu'est ce
qui nous plaisait un peu moins proposer
des thématiques un peu cibler un public
qui pourrait qui pourra apprécier ce
type de films donc là par exemple ce
soir on a on a proposé notre premier
film qui est sûre la musique électro
donc on a ciblé un peu des thèmes pour
ensuite choisir des films
après il fallait négocier aussi les prix
de diffusion externe donc c'est pas
toujours été simple mais bon on arrive à
avoir une programmation qui nous conte
bilingue
c'est essentiel si on vient justement
cette programmation quatre films à
l'affiché des courts métrages aussi
alors il ya du cinéma français ewen et
autrichiens et allemands avec un intérêt
aussi pour le cinéma indépendant donc ce
choix comment s'est il opéré quel est le
tel est le programme justement alors le
programme donc ça a commencé ce soir
comme je vous le disais demande un autre
un autre film qui est projeté tpe 6 et
un film taiwanais vous venez de le dire
et donc chaque film on a essayé de les
accompagner avec des interventions donc
devant proposons concerts par exemple
mercredi vous avez deux de réalisateurs
qui viennent on projette leur leur court
métrage ils ont été sélectionnés aux
césars présélectionnés pardon et jeudi
on a un photographe aussi qui nous vient
donc votre question ce titre la
programmation eouzan vous en avez dit
deux mots donc il ya du court métrage
l'âge du film projeté il l'idée c'est de
proposer des rencontres qu'on est là
pour accompagner les films pour proposer
quelque chose de nouveau un public a
peut-être pas forcément l'habitude de
rencontrer ce type de film parce qu'au
cinéma
ces films là ce ne sont pas proposées
enfin du moins lui en cours ce n'est pas
le cas donc on a essayé de
d'allier les deux pour proposer une
programmation la plus la plus originale
la plus compatible avec le public et nos
intérêts à nous aussi
enfin les lélés les valeurs quand vous
les mettre dans le projet tout notre
projections sont gratuites
entrée libre donc c'était aussi quelque
chose qui nous tenait à coeur et pas
besoin de réservation donc vous pouvez
fermer et on retrouve tout le programme
sur l'événement facebook qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci clara merci
israël pour cette présentation cette
semaine est dédiée au cinéma étranger
qui se déroule jusqu'à vendredi à
guyancourt un autre plaisir après le
cinéma celui de lire qui a été célébrée
pendant toute une soirée la quatrième
édition de la nuit de la lecture s'est
déroulée partout en france samedi à
saint quentin en yvelines la médiathèque
17 mar à elancourt a accueilli un public
familial au retour sur cette
manifestation avec aurélie rond et
maryline yapi chine ont un accent
chantant qui invitait à l'évasion
pour cette quatrième édition de la nuit
de la lecture la médiathèque 17 mar à
elancourt avait notamment misé sur ce
duo de conteurs et leur spectacle
improvisé et rêveur rêveuse j'aime bien
partager les histoires avec les gens je
trouve que vraiment ça permet de partir
dans l'imaginaire est ça nourrit les
adultes et les enfants
je vais très bien les stars étaient
magnifiques
objectif de cette manifestation annuelle
mettre en avant la lecture et les lieux
associé cette année à saint quentin en
yvelines toutes les animations étaient
concentrés à lille on court on a mis le
focus sur la médiathèque 17 mar qui est
une médiathèque particulière c'est la
première médiathèque du réseau jusqu'à
21h le public a pu assister à des
spectacles ou encore à des sciences de
lecture ce rendez vous littéraire marque
est également à 50 ans ni ville le
premier temps fort de la 19e édition de
la fête du conte
ça serait bien qu'ils fassent de plus en
plus en plus dans la médiathèque quand
les gels et les enfants ils ont adoré
c'est génial qui essaient juste à côté
voilà après
on a toujours envie de plus parce que ça
nous fait voyager et pour donner encore
plus envie de dévorer les mots il était
possible de déguster ses personnages de
conte préféré sous forme de cupcakes et
autres gourmandises
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
avec michael el nido robond soir un ca
grégory on commence ce tour d'horizon
michael part du football américain les
templiers d'elancourt qui ont débuté
leur saison en deuxième division cette
année encore les élans courtois
accueillez ce samedi à 18h janvier au
complexe sportif europe les léopards de
rouen l'occasion pour les joueurs
évinois de montrer les muscles et le
potentiel de l'équipe dans cette
deuxième division
mais le match ne tourne pas en faveur
des élans pour toi les joueurs locaux
sont dominés et perdre la partie sur le
score de 22 à 9
l'objectif de montée en fin de saison
n'est pas encore remise en question mais
les joueurs devront trouver rapidement
des automatismes pour emporter à des
victoires on écoute le directeur sportif
il ya un mélange d'anciens et de et de
juniors qui venait qui sont issus des
des sections jeunes qui venaient polluer
dans la première saison en senior
donc ça change un peu donc voila voila
temps d'adaptation
voilà quoi faut qu'après je pense que
quand ils ont rempli leur moi qui
pouvait bien là pour apporter à
décrypter les templiers à joueront leur
deuxième match de la saison le samedi à
1er février quant au lait contre l'émir
mis dans deux savigne le temps toujours
à domicile une équipe qui a remporté son
premier match de la saison 1 contre
nantes du football toujours mais ce
qu'on appelle du soccer à notre côté de
l'atlantique la 2e division de district
de football ce dimanche 19 janvier les
jaunes de plaisir recevait les verts de
rambouillet deux équipes à la lutte pour
le maintien en d2 de district après
quelques minutes d'observation les rangs
boli temps ouvre la marque mais plaisir
revient au score grâce à ce tir en angle
fermé 1 partout un électrochoc pour les
visiteurs qui arrivent à marquer deux
fois avant la mi temps 3 pour
rambouillet en deuxième période plaisir
revient avec de meilleures intentions le
bloc défensif et plus haut c'est grâce
aux coups de pied arrêtés que les
joueurs plaisir avant de revenir au
score deux corners décisifs 3 3 à 15
minutes de la fin du match malgré
quelques situations dangereuses
les deux équipes se séparent sur un
match nul spectaculaire ce résultat
n'arrange aucune des deux équipes dans
la course au maintien à rambouillet
toujours neuvièmes du classement et
plaisir à 10e merci michael haineux pour
ne rien rater un bien sûr de l'actualité
sportive yvelinoise votre émission le
cetud sport après journal et je crois
que vous
annoncerait une bonne nouvelle côté
golfe je n'en dis pas plus ce rendez
vous tout à l'heure le le journal qui va
se terminer tout de suite avec la page
municipal avec un scrutin au programme
les 15 et 22 mars prochain maire sortant
bertrand où lyon se lance pour un
troisième mandat magny les hameaux
après des cafés citoyens en décembre
afin de dresser le bilan de sa
précédente mandature il organise en ce
début d'année des ateliers citoyens pour
préparer son programme les précisions de
mélanie poké un nouveau mandat pour
rester dans la continuité
le collectif ensemble pour magny les
hameaux se lance dans la campagne
municipale autour de bertrand ou lyon à
la tête de la commune depuis 2012
un engagement collectif autour de quatre
grandes orientations solidarité
participation citoyenne bien vivre
ensemble et transition écologique
transition écologique c'est ce qu'on a
déjà entamé sur la commune s'est
continuée transformer date commune pour
pouvoir l'adapter et lutter contre le
changement climatique
c'est des éléments qu'on a déjà commencé
en terme de rénovation de du des
équipements publics en termes de rognes
renaturation de la ville en termes de
diversification agricole pour une
alimentation locale plus saine en termes
de mobilité avec les circulations douces
et nos interventions vis-à-vis de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
d'ile-de-france mobilité pour avoir plus
de bus plus d'expression des ateliers
citoyens sont en cours pour finaliser le
projet si la liste des 29 nom n'est pas
encore totalement établi
bertrand ou lyon repart avec un
renouvellement de 50% de l'équipe je les
rejoins parce que je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire au niveau
solidarité au niveau associatif au
niveau interne générationnel dans la
commune
et puis ça qui m'intéresse
particulièrement aux 6
c'est une ouverture parce qu'il est
bonne idée de partout est ce que propose
le maire sortant candidat c'est
justement allé puiser les bonnes idées
le collectif ensemble pour magny les
hameaux propose un nouvel atelier
citoyen mardi 21 janvier à la salle de
festivités deux autres candidats se sont
déclarés sur la commune dominique
grattepain élus de la majorité de 1995 à
2001 et lionel lindemann actuellement
membre de l'opposition à maurepas il
sera candidat pour la deuxième fois
ismail havane bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
gauche vous êtes la tête de liste de
maurepas dynamique et solidaire pour ce
scrutin en 2014 on rappelle que vous
aviez totalisé 13 33% des voix au second
tour face au maire élu grégory gary sied
aussi à michel chat pas pourquoi se
lancer de nouveau dans cette campagne
des municipales
tout d'abord c'est un rendez vous que
nous avons donnée il ya six ans déjà je
ne sais pas si vous étés au moment
présent au moment de delà des résultats
qui étaient annoncés en micro en mairie
mais j'avais annoncé au mort pas un
rendez vous dans six ans nous y sommes
donc je suis candidat pour ce rendez
vous que nous avions données et parce
que aussi nous avons un certain nombre
d'idées et de valeurs apportées dans
cette commune qui ce qui a besoin je
pense de changement de renouveau et nous
allons en parler tout à l'heure avec le
but peut-être de refaire basculer mort
pas à gauche la ville a été un pendant
25 ans sous l'égide de georges mougeot
avant de basculer à droite en 2014 un
scrutin où la gauche était partie
divisée
à l'époque il y avait trois mêmes quatre
listes de gauche au premier tour
pas d'union également au deuxième tour
visiblement la gauche ne va pas repartir
unis encore une fois pour cette élection
alors je ne sais pas de quoi vous parlez
pour être honnête en 2014 puisque vous
parlez de 2014 trois adjoints se sont
présentés à la municipale vous adjoint
de l'ancien de majorité georges toujours
majorité à laquelle je n'appartenais pas
donc c'est à eux qu'il faut poser la
question
ce qui est sûr c'est que en 2014 ma
liste était un conte et l union de la
gauche pour le coup parce qu'il y avait
le parti communiste
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste donc l'union de la gauche
était fait à cette époque là en tout cas
pour pour notre part
et aujourd'hui il faut se tourner vers
l'avenir ça c'est le passé et parler des
projets qui intéressent les mort passe
bien et nous sommes dans une logique
complètement différente que je souhaite
exposer ce soir où il y avait quand même
plusieurs listes de tendance de gauche
en 2014
alors cette fois-ci vous mènerez cette
liste avec à vos côtés martin fayolle
qui est fait partie de votre groupe
d'opposition c'est que vous avez une
sensibilité à gauche il se met il à
vannes vous est d'ailleurs toujours
adhérent au parti socialiste même si
vous dites vous en êtes éloignée depuis
2010 est est ce que votre liste sera de
gauche et ce qu'elle rassemblera
diverses sensibilités politiques pour
être très précis
ma liste kate une liste plutôt notre
liste parce que nous sommes plusieurs et
une liste sans étiquette
moi je suis de gauche je vais toujours
dit tout le monde le sais j'étais
conseiller général socialiste soit quand
il me semble quand on ne mord pas donc
je suis de gauche et je le reste on a ce
sont mes valeurs
néanmoins ce sont des valeurs qui sont
contemporaines et qui ne changent pas
dans le temps contrairement à des partis
qui sont l'incarnation normalement de
des valeurs auxquelles on adhère qui
peuvent être changeant comme vous pouvez
vous en douter mais aujourd'hui
effectivement nous sommes sur une liste
sans étiquette et que j'ai l'honneur de
conduire et j'ai le plaisir d'avoir des
hommes et des femmes qui ont une
intelligence d'esprit et une ouverture
d'esprit pour pouvoir travailler sur un
projet commun quelquefois quelles que
soient les horizons et des parcours
qu'ils ont eue pour en terminer sur
votre question la liste est composée
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont pour
certains et certaines de gauche qui
viennent de gauche qui sont encartés
d'autres ne le sont pas certains et
certaines du centre et d'autre ça a été
aussi notre surprise lorsqu'on a fait
cet appel un large rassemblement de
droite mais ce qu'il convient de dire
c'est qu'ils partagent tous cette idée
d'avoir un projet commun bâti autour de
valeurs humanistes et qu'est-ce que vous
revendiquez un soutien une investiture
du parti socialiste d'europe écologie
les verts pourquoi pas moi je ne
revendique rien du tout la nature même
d'une liste sans étiquette si elle ne
veut pas se trahir
c'est de rester fidèle à ce large
rassemblement que nous avons demandé et
qui en train de se réaliser donc je ne
revendique rien du tout
après libre à chacun de se retrouver
dans les idées que nous défendons et à
ce titre peut-être c'est le sens de
votre question nous sommes des hommes et
des femmes ouverts et nous vous invitons
lors de notre prochain veut député
européen europe ecologie les verts mais
s'il s'agissait d'une autre personnalité
encarté dans un parti ou non qui
adhèrent à nos idées nous l'aurions
aussi invités alors vous qui avez été
dans l'opposition pendant ces six
dernières années quel regard vous portez
sur la mandature du maire sortant
grégory des restes y est je porte un
regard assez critique et je me dis aussi
qu'il y a un certain gâchis gâchis parce
que je comprends qu'en 2014 les
morlaisiens ont espéré un renouveau
puisque nous avons un maire jeunes et
donc du coup ancré dans son dans son
époque
force est de constater que aujourd'hui
d'urgence de notre époque c'est la
transition écologique
c'est un sujet transports complètement
oublié durant cette mandature et ça fera
partie d'un de vos quatre axes
prioritaires et a fait alors c'était un
de nos piliers en 2014 et nous avons
créé ce large ressemble rassemblement
autour justement de l'idée de la
transition écologique et il ya cinq ans
donc ce n'est pas un effet de mode
on n'a pas fait pour les élections
municipales on a construit ce groupe il
ya cinq ans et donc du coup c'est notre
adn
et c'est pourquoi votre première
question pourquoi se présenter c'est
parce qu'il ya des choses à faire et en
urgence dans notre ville face au
bétonnage que vous avez certainement
constaté alors le bétonnage qui aussi
répond à un besoin en logements sociaux
qui sont environ 2 18% sur la commune de
maurepas on sait qu'il ya des impératifs
imposés par l'état d'atteindre ces 25 %
de logements sociaux comment justement
apporte une réponse en se pliant aux
exigences de l'état et sans faire de
bétonisation il ya un projet d'éco
quartier qui est menée à maurepas ce
n'est pas une bonne réponse apportée on
a le droit d'attenter légende
effectivement les hommes et des femmes
ont besoin d'habitat pour se loger mais
pas de problème sur ce constat là
cependant il faut faire les choses de
manière intelligente et construite dans
le temps
aujourd'hui nous avons construit de
manière intense et rapide
à tel point que le bon sens a été oublié
le bon sens c'est quoi c'est toutes les
structures qui font force les écoles les
crèches les transports qui n'ont pas été
pensés et dimensionner suffisamment par
rapport à cet afflux de nouveaux
habitants qui vont arriver
ensuite et c'est un peu dommage sur ce
projet que qui s'appelle écoquartier il
aurait pu être et dû être beaucoup plus
ambitieux pour d'un point de vue
écologique est réellement répondre à la
norme à ce qu eux qu'ils ne répondent
pas aujourd'hui et nous allons le
démontrer lors de nos prochains prochain
veux et je trouve que c'est un gâchis et
surtout pour les mortuaciens des
problèmes de dimensionnement à venir au
niveau des structures locales en trois
autres piliers pour votre candidature la
démocratie le pluralisme et la justice
sociale c'est ce qu'a fait alors un mot
sur la démocratie c'est quelque chose de
ex de très important notre beau pays la
france pays de la liberté de la
démocratie a dans ses institutions
locales généré quand même quelques
effets qu'il faut corriger
rien n'interdit aujourd'hui d'avoir un
maire élu démontra démocratiquement mais
qui se comporte comme un potentat local
et qui fait ce qu'il veut
le plus emblématique face à une
caricature qui n'a rien à voir avec le
débat aujourd'hui c'est balkany qui d'un
point de vue clientéliste alors qu'il a
été élu démocratiquement se permet de
faire un peu ce qu'il veut dans sa ville
alors pour corriger cela ce que nous
proposons nous dans notre dans notre
programme c'est d'avoir une nouvelle
gouvernance locale qui associe beaucoup
plus finement les habitants au projet et
à la vie de la cité et biella
participatif mise en place par la
majorité actuelle fasse pas suffisante
ce n'est pas suffisant leur budget
participatif c'était aussi dans notre
projet en 2014 mais ce n'est pas
suffisant nous souhaitons remettre une
forme de comités de quartier renouveler
redistribuer qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui à maurepas et qui est je
pense la base quand même d'une
démocratie et surtout que chaque projet
soit étudié dans le comité de quartier
et que les habitants et la primauté des
projets de construction et aussi la
parole et pourquoi pas la votation sur
les sujets d'orientation tels que ça n'a
pas été le cas pour la piscine par
exemple la piscine intercommunale avec
eux et long cours qui était l'un des
sujets phares sur cette fin de mandature
on le disait donc deux autres axes
justice sociale qu réalisme ça tout à
fait le pluralisme vous l'avez compris
notre liste sans étiquette pluralisme ça
veut dire que c'est ouvert à tout le
monde
pure pluralisme ce qui montre d'ailleurs
notre ouverture d'esprit et si je pense
que c'est dans l'air du temps et c'est
aussi notre adn justice sociale parce
qu'un certain nombre d'habitants en
particulier la jeunesse à maurepas que
nous avons rencontrés au cours de nos
nombreux porte à porte se sentent
complètement délaissé perdu ce sentiment
est renforcé encore une fois par le fait
que nous avons un maire jeunes et les
jeunes en particulier se reconnaissent
pas dans ce maire qui quelque part les
amis de côté en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils
nous disent est ce que nous constatons
réellement et nous avons des
propositions à faire sur ce sujet
dernière chose qu'on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien votre prochain rendez vous
de campagne
merci alors le prochain rendez vous de
campagne c'est lundi 27 janvier à 20
heures à la salle des coudrais route
bassigny où nous faisons nos voeux
annuels depuis cinq ans et pour cette
année avec la particularité des
élections nous avons invité mounir
satory donc des buts député europe
ecologie les verts député européen et
nous profiterons de cet événement pour
donner plus de détails sur la thématique
de la transition écologique et nous
ferons des mesures ou nous proposerons
des mesures qui sont assez innovante au
mort pas aimer au magazine merci ça ils
avaient en tête de liste maurepas
dynamique et solidaire pour ce scrutin
face à vous je rappelle qu'il y aura à
le maire sortant divers droite grégory
galeriste ya également un michel chapa
qui est aussi conseiller municipal
d'opposition et qui conduira une liste
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]